this holiday season inflation and the
pandemic impacting the demand on Bay
Area food banks a volunteer there knows
what it's like to grow up Hungary and
her experience is driving her to help
others like her Reed cow and now telling
us the story and her tie to Southern
Nevada
the face of hunger is changing and the
need is great we know the strains of the
economy make it so difficult for so many
and that means the person you pass in
the hallways at school or at church May
indeed be hungry this next story is
about a woman who grew up in Las Vegas
and really knew what it was like to face
food insecurity she's proof that people
who are hungry might be right there next
to you hiding in plain sight
sometimes the last person you would
think was ever hungry got a stack of 20.
is right there in the room with you and
the last person all right who's your
friend you want to you want to do this
you would ever think could make the
story of food insecurity land in the
heart this moment should I say it I
think so was when Food Bank volunteer
Karen let out a truth she hadn't spoken
in years my name is Karen and I am here
volunteering because I experienced
housing and food insecurity as a child
Karen used to be this little girl whose
single mom fell on hard times and we
wound up living in a tent at Lake Mead
and we relied
on the generosity of those around us all
that separated us from any type of
dangers in the world was a flimsy piece
of canvas and a miniature dachshund
Karen has only a handful of photographs
from those days this one wearing a
borrowed dress for a church photo I
dreaded this day because I knew all the
girls were gonna have these beautiful
white dresses and veils and
gloves and shoes and we were living in a
tent at this exact moment I felt like an
actual princess that day granted we had
come from washing my hair in a spigot
with
hand soap it's knowing what hunger feels
like food means a lot to me that makes
Karen cooking dinner at home no small
luxury when Karen Cooks she remembers
collecting spent soda cans with her
brother once we had enough we would
redeem them at the marina for a
cheeseburger and my brother and I would
share it and she remembers watching the
face of her mom as her children ate a
shared dollar hamburger my mom would
often at every time say that she had
already eaten she was full she didn't
eat anything so my dad would take us
every other weekend
for visitations and my mom would tell us
as we were leaving on Friday night eat
whatever you can just eat do you still
cry for that little girl I do
I do I I feel sad for her and for her
brother and for my mom so what do you do
when things hurt and when memories haunt
you live like Karen who channels the
pain of hunger when she was a child into
helping others I don't believe that
children and families should go hungry
not at the holidays not year-round and
I just want to help out I would imagine
for you it's not just a bag you're
wondering whose hands it goes into yeah
I'm wondering
what children are going to go to school
with a cool
lunch box where they get the you know
the name brand juice box and the string
cheese in many parts of the Bay Area
children make up 25 of those who need
help that is extended to thousands where
we live the stories of our little ones
you just don't know you never know what
people are going through and what their
story is sometimes hiding in plain sight
you do know people they just don't don't
show it outwardly and so Karen would say
thank you to so many people in southern
Nevada who made sure that she and her
mother and her brother did not go hungry
and to continue to power the food banks
there in southern Nevada she says and I
will Echo it myself there are no better
people on planet Earth than the great
people of Southern Nevada
in the Bay Area read Cowan back to you